Music man, lead us off.
Hello and welcome to this
MIT virtual town hall.
And thank you, Marty Marks, of
MIT's Music and Theater Arts
section for that wonderful
opening music from Jerome Kern.
I'm Alfred Ironside, vice
president for Communications,
welcoming you to the second
in a series of gatherings
across our community.
In a moment, I'll hand off to
Rafael Reif, president of MIT,
and our outstanding panel
of faculty and staff.
But first, a few reminders
on accessibility.
We are live
captioning this event
and also have simultaneous
sign language translation.
Notices for both were
sent out in advance.
We also have an
audio-only call in line
for those without a strong
internet connection.
And this event is
being recorded and will
be available at this
URL for viewing anytime.
Now to our format.
As with our first
town hall, we have
gathered some of your
questions in advance,
but this time, we will also be
responding to your questions
live, as many as we can get to.
You can submit questions
through the Q&A feature
at the bottom of your screen.
Our purpose today is
to offer an update
to share what we know about
the complex factors shaping
the decisions ahead
of MIT and there are
a lot of factors to talk about.
So let's begin.
With pleasure, I pass the floor
to MIT President Rafael Reif.
Thank you, Alfred, and to
our students, and parents,
and staff, and faculty, alumni--
warm greetings from Cambridge.
Actually to be more precise,
warm greetings from Gray House.
We are all members
of the MIT community.
And that means we have a
lot of things in common.
Among those, we care for one
another and we care for MIT.
COVID-19 has affected and
it's affecting all of us.
But it's affecting some
much harder than others.
So as we work on solutions
with the challenge of COVID-19
on our campus, let's
recognize, let's
be sensitive that each of
us is experiencing COVID-19
differently.
And each of us had
different points of view.
So let's respect
those differences
and let's show empathy
for those who are going
through a very difficult time.
And let's find solutions that
work for our whole community.
We had closed our campus
about eight weeks ago or so.
Four weeks ago, we had
our first town hall.
Since that town hall,
we updated the community
on our financial situation.
We also shared some
decisions on the summer.
Today's town hall is not to
share additional decisions.
Actually, today's
town hall is mostly
to share our thinking about
decisions we have yet to meet.
And top of that list is when and
how we will reopen the campus.
We have not made
that decision yet.
We have many people from all
parts of the campus working
together to come up
with scenarios on
how we can reopen
the campus and when.
All these individuals are
organized in working groups,
and the leaders of all
those working groups
are with us today to
share their thinking
and to answer your questions.
In addition to
them, we also have
members of the
central administration
that will be available to
answer your questions, as well.
One of the most
important issues that we
have to consider before deciding
how and when to open the campus
is the state of the
public health situation
and the state of
medical science.
And for that, we have
a terrific guest today,
a person that I deeply admire.
An MIT professor
of the practice who
is also the director of the
Reagan Institute of MTH, MIT,
and Harvard.
And this is Dr. Bruce Walker.
He is on the frontlines of
much of the research going
on these days to
overcome COVID-19
and he is a terrific
advisor to all of us.
Bruce, thank you so
much for joining us.
Happy to be here.
Bruce, the picture
is so complex.
I would like, if you can,
to just clarify it for us.
So before we open
the campus, we have
to pay attention to social
distancing and testing
and tracing and
medical treatments,
perhaps even vaccines.
What can you tell us
about the landscape?
How would you advise us to
consider the landscape in terms
of reopening the campus?
There's an experiment
going on right
now that I think is giving us
knowledge that helps direct
those sorts of decisions.
And that experiment is
happening in hospitals
across the country.
Mass General is one example,
where I work as a clinician.
And the reality is that using
personal protective equipment
and monitoring for symptoms
has resulted in health workers
actually being able to be safe.
The problems for
health care workers
have come when they
haven't had masks to use
and they haven't had the
additional personal protective
equipment when they're
interfacing directly
with patients.
I think the emerging
data suggests
that if you wear a mask and
everybody else wears a mask,
the chances of transmission
drop dramatically.
I think if you add to
that frequent temperature
monitoring, the chances
of transmission drop
even more, because you can
identify people with a fever
right away, and remove them
then from the community.
And so what we need to think
about is what resources
do we have right
now, what knowledge
do we have right now
that might guide us
and I think the knowledge we
have is a suggestion that--
a pretty firm suggestion-- that
the judicious use of masks,
and social distancing
or physical distancing,
and symptom and
temperature monitoring
will have a dramatic
impact on transmissibility.
As you probably are
guessing or knowing,
there is tremendous anxiety on
when we will open the campus.
And for that, we need to use
the information you told us.
At the same time,
we also have to try
to imagine and have a
crystal ball on what little
we know that is
different from today
perhaps four weeks from now,
perhaps eight weeks from now.
If we will know
nothing different,
then we might as well
make a decision right now.
Things are changing-- what
can you tell us about that?
I'm not suggesting you
can tell us exactly
what's going to happen--
nobody has a crystal ball--
or perhaps you do.
But my main point is, what
do you think might change?
Why is that we probably
should wait as long as we can
as opposed to deciding today?
I think there are
a couple of things
that will become apparent.
One of them is
surveys to understand
just how many people
have been infected
and just how close to
herd immunity we may be.
Herd immunity is
when enough people
have been exposed that
the likelihood of one
person encountering
an uninfected person
diminishes to the point where
ongoing transmissions become
less.
We don't yet know if
antibodies are protective,
but there's reason to
assume that those are.
And we'll know more about that
from animal experiments that
are ongoing right now I think
that will help to guide that.
But I think we'll begin
to get a sense of just
how widespread the
infection has been.
And I think that that'll be
important information for us
to understand.
I think also, as tests
become more available,
we'll be better able
to monitor for example
the whole population at MIT
to when students come back
to follow them.
I think the other
really important thing
that's a little bit
further on the horizon
is the development of high
throughput, inexpensive,
saliva-based testing
for virus itself.
And we sponsored a
webinar on Friday
that I'd love to
send out and make
available to the people on
this town hall to watch.
There are some
extraordinary advances
being made by professors at
MIT and their graduate students
and postdocs that give me
reason to think that it's
within the foreseeable
future that you can get up
in the morning, and brush your
teeth, and at the same time,
take a Q-Tip and swirl it
around your [INAUDIBLE]
and stick it in a tube, and
have it turn a color if you're
infected and not turn
color if you're not.
We will get out of
this predicament
that we're in because of science
and engineering and technology.
And MIT is the focal point of
that in the world, in my view.
And when you watch
what is happening
on this on this
webinar from people
like Feng Jiang
and others, you'll
have reason to be hopeful.
Thank you so very
much for joining us.
I really appreciate it.
And you have always been
available to us to advise us.
And we will keep
abusing your time for us
as long as you let us.
Thank you so much.
You're welcome.
I think we're going
to move now to what
I mentioned at the beginning.
We have different working
groups working together
to try to come up with
scenarios for us for the fall.
We have working groups
on residential life,
on academic, on research, on the
use of physical space and staff
and community.
There appear to be
differing, but the truth
is that all those
recommendations, everything
they're coming up with,
really, those elements are
intertwined with each other.
So we really have to have not
just working on those areas,
but working them
together, which is
why we're going to
just introduce them
right now jointly, and
ask a few questions.
And then they'll be ready to
answer your own questions.
So let's start with
our [INAUDIBLE]..
And that's for Suzy Nelson to
start with, our vice president
and being for student life.
Suzy, thank you for
joining us today.
I hear from you and others
that the number one challenge
you're facing,
we're all facing, is
how to repopulate the campus.
And that includes how to
bring stuff back, the faculty,
the students, and
postdocs, and so forth.
Your big responsibility
is, of course,
students, and dorms
or residence halls.
So what are your views?
What are you thinking about
repopulating this fall when
it comes to residential areas?
Thank you, Rafael.
Hi, everyone.
Thanks so much
for joining today.
Let me just provide a
little bit of context,
because we actually have 2,000
people living in residence now.
We have 1,300 graduate students,
and 200 undergraduate students,
and around 500 partners,
and spouses, and children,
and house team members.
And so as we look to
the fall, I will say,
we've been thinking
really hard on this,
but we still have a lot
more questions than answers.
And the main point that
I want to make today
is that we really want students
to help us problem solve.
And there's a few ways
that they can do that.
The first is we have been
sending out some surveys
to those who live in residence
and those who live off campus.
And we've been asking you to
tell us about your experience.
And that really helps us think
about what the fall might
look like, having a good sense
of how it is for you right now.
And the second is yesterday,
we invited all students
to take a look at a problem
statement that's online.
And we created a We
Solve for Fall idea bank,
and we would really like
you to engage with us
all the questions that we have.
There's a lot of
resources there,
some that Bruce just mentioned,
that you could take a look at.
But we would like you to
engage with us in that way.
And we also invite you to
join one of too many townhall
meetings that we will have
after this big townhall.
Those will be held
on Wednesday, May 13.
One will be for
graduate students
And the other will be
for undergraduates.
They will be hosted
by our student
leaders and our heads of house.
So please look for those
details and we really
hope that you'll attend.
And then finally, as we
think about these problems,
I think they can be framed
in really two goals.
The first goal is
that we know we
will have some new constraints.
But how can we look at
this in a creative way
and really reimagine
the MIT campus
so that it's
positive, and special,
and as intellectually
and personally engaging
as we want it to be.
And then the second big goal
is as we make these decisions,
how can we be sure we prioritize
community health and well-being
for all who are here on campus.
So within these
two main goals, we
have some considerations that I
think students can think about
and what all of us
can think about.
What values should play
into these decisions
and how should we make
these housing assignments
for our students
when they return.
What strategies will
be the most effective
as we try to manage
the spread of the virus
and keep our community
healthy, especially
in our residence halls.
And then finally,
how do we get buy in
and how do we
communicate effectively
about these new ideas so
that they can be implemented
with some effectiveness.
We're really
fortunate because we
have faculty who
live in our houses
and I'm very happy
that two heads of house
are joining us today.
And they have a
lot of experience
certainly as professors,
but they also
have experience living in
residence with our students.
So I want to give them
a moment to talk as well
about what they're seeing
in the residence halls
and how they view this.
David Singer, he's our
department head and professor
of political science, and
he lives in MacGregor House
in undergraduate community.
And Julie Shah is a
professor in AeroAstro,
and she's the head of house
in Sydney Pacific, which is
a graduate student community.
So David, let's
turn to you first.
Could you offer some
thoughts on what
you think about what's
before us this fall?
Again, thank you, Suzy.
Happy to be here.
When we think about
Suzy's these questions
in the context of the
undergraduate dorms,
two considerations jump out.
First is that every
dorm is different.
They range in size from
93 to 500 residents.
And they have different
configurations
of rooms, bathrooms, kitchens,
lounges, dining halls,
and common spaces.
And second, each dorm has its
own form of student government
that serves as a Steward of
that community's traditions.
So I think the way forward
in the coming weeks
and months will be for each
residential community to think
about how students
circulate in each community,
to think about how to
foster social interactions
and in a safe manner.
And that we're partnering
with modeling experts
from IDSS and other
units, and we're listening
to experts like Dr. Walker.
And for the students
in each community
to take the lead in
designing new guidelines
that respect the unique
physical and social features
of each community and
that also, importantly,
respect the safety of the
more vulnerable members
of each community.
And this is MIT, so the outcome
will be a new traditions.
It will hopefully
be clever strategies
that no one's thought of before.
And importantly,
continuity in some
of the core aspects of
residential life that make
MIT a special place
to live and to study.
Great.
Thank you, David.
Julie, what are some of
your observations as head
of house in Sydney Pacific?
Thank you, Suzy.
So I'm currently in a dorm
with more than 400 students,
and I can say that Sydney
Pacific exemplifies
what a thriving campus community
looks like, despite these very
challenging circumstances.
We have a strong
community in SP,
but frankly, our
community does seem
to depend on
physical gatherings.
And back in March,
I will admit, I
did worry for a moment that
social distancing would
bring everything to a
halt. And that was silly.
You know, we have
weekly movie nights,
game made, virtual dinner
series, group coloring
sessions, book clubs, and
many other events continue on,
both for those that are
on campus and off campus.
And it's small efforts to make
each other feel heard and cared
for that have gone a long way.
Our students are not only
coping, but they're innovating.
So seemingly overnight, they
mobilized the collaboration
with MIT Medical to implement
suppression measures
against the coronavirus.
The effort was actually sparked
by two questions in the dorm--
can we understand utilization
of our common spaces
in the dorms like common
kitchens, bathrooms, laundry,
and the risk of exposure to
the virus in these places?
Grad students are now
working with Lincoln Lab
to help test and improve
privacy-preserving mobile apps
that may help in
alerting residents
of potential exposures.
Thanks to our students.
There'll be ways for more
to get involved soon.
And it's really all very
MIT and it's something
to make us all very proud.
Thanks, David and thanks, Julie.
Those are great
thoughts and comments.
And again, we really
appreciate your partnership
and we are looking forward
to working together
with the students.
So please go to the
Idea Bank and also,
join us for the many townhalls,
which will be next week.
Rafael, I'll pass
it back to you.
Thank you, Suzy.
Thank you very
much for everything
you do with so much
care for us student.
And thank you, David and
Julie, for joining us, as well.
Moving on to
academic continuity.
And that working group
is led by Ian Waitz,
our vice chancellor for
undergraduate and graduate
application.
Ian, can you tell
us a little bit
about the scenarios
you're thinking?
How are you beginning to
envision options for us
for the fall?
Thank you, Rafael.
So I would say first,
at an individual level,
we're anticipating that
we will have staff members
faculty, students
who either may be ill
or may be high risk individuals
so that we can have situations
where we have
faculty who can't be
on the physical campus
and students who can
and vice versa.
So we have to be
two-way remote capable
for much of our curriculum.
That's a heavy lift.
But we're preparing to do that.
The bigger question that
I think a lot of people
are interested in is what will
the fall look like in terms
of how much online
education will we have,
and how much in-person
and what does it
mean to be socially
distanced in our instructional
spaces, and labs, and project
spaces, and classrooms,
and things like that.
And as I listen to
Bruce, it's pretty clear
that things are changing so
rapidly that one of the best
things that we can do is
plan for multiple different
scenarios very, very vigorously,
and prepare for those,
but wait to make decisions
until we learn more.
So we're planning
for things that
go all the way from a
fully online fall to having
all of the students back, to
things that are in between--
half the students
for half the time.
And I, at least as
an optimist at heart,
am very hopeful that we will
have at least some students
on campus in the fall.
But it's constrained, obviously,
by a social distancing
and by testing methodologies
and things like that.
So we're still working with a
range of different scenarios
so that we can be prepared as we
learn more in the weeks ahead.
There's so many people
that are working on this.
I want to highlight a sort
of a couple individuals
who've been very
helpful in thinking
through different
aspects of this.
One is Rick Danheiser,
the chair of the faculty,
who has just in a wonderfully
thoughtful way, helped
reimagine and
rebuild the policies
as we go through
this whole process.
And so I'll first
turn to Rick and ask
if he can comment a little
bit about all of that,
because it's just an important
part of moving forward
in whatever we do.
Rick?
Thanks, Ian.
Good afternoon, everyone.
As I described in an email
letter to the community
just this past weekend, I'm
leading the academic policy
and regulations team we call
APART, of faculty and students,
which the faculty
officers created
in mid-April as a
successor to the emergency
academic regulations
or EARS team.
You may recall that it
was the EARS team that
developed those emergency
regulations, including
the pass/no record
grading scheme
in effect for the spring.
So as we formulate the
policies associated
with our academic
program for this summer
and that will apply in
the fall, the APART team
has been guided by
several principles.
First and foremost, our
aim is to develop policies
that will promote and support
an educational experience
for undergraduate
and graduate students
that is as full, as enriching,
and as rewarding as possible.
At the same time, we
strive to recognize
and be sensitive to the fact
that individual students
and individual
instructors may be facing
very different challenges
and obstacles as we navigate
our way through the
current emergency.
As one example, this week,
the academic policy team
is working to finalize a
plan for student and subject
surveys.
From the outset,
the team recognized
that the usual numerical subject
evaluation system was not
appropriate for this unusual
semester in which instructors
in many cases had less
than two weeks to jury
rig a remote version
of their subjects--
sometimes while
simultaneously dealing
with health and personal
challenges of their own.
At the same time,
APART appreciates
that we have a responsibility to
gather feedback from and listen
to our students.
And we do not want to
lose the opportunity
to gather valuable
input and advice on how
to improve our core
subjects, should it
be necessary to offer remote
versions again in the future.
So with the help of
advice from students
and the expertise of the MIT
Teaching and Learning Lab,
I believe that the system we
are developing and will announce
hopefully within a week
will achieve these goals
and prove valuable
to the community
as we plot our course
forward in the future, Ian.
Thanks, Rick.
Just one of dozens
and dozens of examples
where Rick and his team,
have worked through faculty
committees and engaging
students and things, to sort of
figure out how best we
can plot the way forward.
I'll also note that Rick is
one of the faculty members
who had two weeks to spin
his class up on its head,
and jury rig it,
and make it work.
So he also has some personal
experience with that.
Both David and Julie mentioned
that so much is happening,
it's just so very MIT--
Bruce Walker did, as well.
One of the things that
will happen in the fall,
no matter what
scenario we have, is
that they're going to be a
lot of very MIT experiences.
And one of the people who has
been helping to imagine those
is associate dean of
engineering, Peko Hosoi.
So I'm going to ask Peko to just
share a little bit about that.
Great.
Thanks, Ian.
Yeah, I want to start by
echoing what you just said
and what Rick said,
which is that I think
the faculty and
students have been put
in an extraordinary position.
And the threat of the resilience
and the response that I've
seen from both of
those communities
have been really remarkable.
And that actually fills me with
a lot of optimism for the fall.
To the students, I think some
of the faculty have adapted
and we're going to get better.
It's kind of just get better
as we've learned more.
So I think bigger, single sort
of umbrella thing that I wanted
to say is that I think MIT--
we've been sort of at our
best when we are stepping up
in the service of
the local community,
in the service of the
nation, and in the service
of the world.
And I think that is not
just true in our research,
but also in our
educational efforts.
So one of my colleagues,
Warren Seering,
has a fabulous
presentation, where
he shows the evolution of
the mechanical engineering
curriculum.
And you see that in
the late 1800s, when
the nation was building
bridges, we were
teaching metallurgy of iron.
Then we went on
the steam engines,
and we dropped metallurgy,
and we put in thermodynamics
and boiler design.
And then we went on
to electrification,
and we dropped boiler design.
And we went on to surveying
and electrical engineering.
And so you can see that our
programs evolve according
to the National needs and
evolve to address problems that
are of immediate relevance.
So I think we're going to
see more and more of that.
I think there are already a lot
of faculty that are doing that.
I think you're seeing groups of
that popping up around campus.
And I applaud everybody
who's putting in that effort.
Great.
Thanks, Peko.
So I think, as I said,
independent of what path we
choose in the fall-- and
I'm sort of optimistic that
we'll have a path that has
at least some of our students
on campus for some of the
time, hopefully more--
I think there'll be some
really great experiences,
great learning experiences
that befit MIT's history
and mission going forward.
And obviously, happy to take
lots of questions on that
later.
Thanks, Rafael.
Thanks to you, Ian.
Let me just say again,
as I said publicly,
I thank you and admire you
for all the work you've done.
It's almost [INAUDIBLE] to
bring it up at this point.
And Rick, thank you also for
joining us in this [INAUDIBLE]..
You have no choice-- you have
to teach, but take you, anyway.
Let's move on to space.
And we have associate
provost Krystyn Van
Vliet, who leads the
Working Group of Space Use.
And Krystyn the question
that some people have is,
well, we have government
guidelines on safe distancing.
How do you anticipate us
practicing those guidelines
in our classrooms?
Krystyn, are you
there somewhere?
I am.
Thanks, Rafael.
That's a very reasonable
question to ask.
Of course, it's on
all of our minds
as we bring even more
people onto the campus.
As Suzy mentioned, we have
people who were on the campus
now but as we bring more people
back, how will we do this?
And I think this is a puzzle.
We enjoy solving
puzzles at MIT, and we
have a very active
and dedicated group
who are thinking about this.
But what's already
clear is that there
will be a lower density of
people in any given space.
So if you think
about a lecture hall,
there will be fewer people
in that lecture hall,
but the education should
and will be just as vibrant.
But it's not just the lecture
halls which are obvious.
It's how well we do
performance-based learning
and project-based learning
and laboratory-based learning.
So we're thinking about
that from every curriculum's
perspective, what will the
classroom of the future, when
we bring more students
back to campus, look like?
And I think it's important to
be aware that that will always
have a few things in mind.
It's not just about bringing
the students back to campus,
but it's about the
well-being of the students
and the faculty and the staff.
And that's all
equally important.
And here, the staff
are the people
who helped to design and
deliver those classes,
to clean the restrooms and the
buildings and the laboratories.
To take care of the research
teams and the administration.
And so as we think about
all of those people being
in the building together, we
think about the well-being
and the flexibility,
and the adaptability
as being important
components of the planning.
Krystyn, thank you.
You've done, also,
an amazing job.
I think you're the only
or one of the very few
that is allowed to go into
every single space on campus.
We don't let anybody else.
So that's a very
dubious privilege
that you give yourself, Krystyn.
Thank you for the work you do.
You're very welcome.
And I should say, we're
all eager to get back
to the campus, Rafael.
The picture behind me I did
take a couple of weeks ago.
So you're right, I
have the privilege
of getting to see the
campus in its current state,
but I'm just as eager
to be back in my lab
and my classroom as anyone else.
I agree with you, Krystyn.
Thank you.
So let's move on to
the research engine.
Lots of people are
asking where are
we going to bring the
research engine back.
And Maria Zuber is
our VP for research.
And hopefully, she is really
close with the question.
Maria, please.
Hi, everybody.
So our efforts in the
research enterprise
are in two critical areas.
The first is funding
continuity and the second
is planning for a phased
opening of our research labs
in a way that prioritizes
the safety of both
the MIT and the
surrounding communities.
So in the area of
funding, we're closely
monitoring our current
grants and future funding
opportunities.
Federal agencies
under OMB guidance
have given great flexibility in
the execution of current grants
for a period of
90 days and we're
working with
government colleagues
and our parents detentions to
advocate for not only funding
enhancements to existing
grants, but also,
talking about the importance
of proceeding with new proposal
solicitations.
Our non-federal partners and
foundations and especially
in industry are undergoing
extraordinary financial
challenges.
And we're in communication
with many of them
to try to minimize the
impacts to our researchers.
And we're working with our
vice president, the financier,
and the provost to understand
the extent of our exposure
so we can develop
mitigating strategies.
Now to plan for the
ramp up of labs,
I instituted a
faculty-led process.
I hope virtual meetings
with over 20 department lab
and center heads to receive
input on the factors
that they considered important
in restarting research
on campus.
I then formed a
committee representing
a subset of this group
supplemented by critical staff
and chaired by
professor Tyler Jacks
to develop guidelines for ramp
up, which we distributed widely
for comment.
The issues raised
were not all academic.
For example, among the
most often-cited needs
are on campus parking
and child care.
The committee is now
coalescing the input
to develop an implementation
plan for a phased lab opening.
While we don't have a firm date
yet to announce at this time,
we're following the guidelines
from the Massachusetts state
officials very closely.
And I'm now going
to turn it over
to Tyler to provide an update
on the committee's activities.
Well, thanks very much, Maria,
and good afternoon, everybody.
Let me say at the outset that
this was a very engaged process
that involved nine MIT faculty
members and several senior MIT
staff, who worked
really effectively
to come up with a
set of guidelines
to help us think
about a sensible way
to come back to our
research activities.
I'll talk about those in
some detail in a second,
but let me start by making
a few general points.
The first is that although
most of our research activities
have moved to the
off campus setting
over the last couple
of months, there
is significant research
taking place at MIT,
including quite a lot in the
area of COVID-19 research.
And Bruce Walker actually
mentioned some of that earlier.
And that's quite exciting.
Secondly, when Maria
constituted the committee,
she was very clear
about the scope,
and specifically that it related
to research that needed access
to laboratories or needed
access to equipment in order
to be done.
And therefore, we assume
that the current policy that
work that can be
done remotely will
be done remotely we'll stay
in place during this phase
of the research ramp up.
And the third general point is
that we recognize that when we
come back to campus
in this fashion,
there will be individuals who
cannot or choose not to come
back for a variety of reasons.
And so the committee
was very clear
that with respect to all members
of research teams coming back,
it would be voluntary.
With respect to the
planning itself,
the committee took
the approach that we
wanted to get back to research.
We're all anxious to
get back to research,
but we have to do
it in a fashion that
represents the safest
possible set of practices.
So therefore, we anticipate
starting with a low density
work environment as
Krystyn described,
that will allow us to be
well within CDC guidelines
in terms of safe work practices.
And over time as
conditions allow,
we envision future phases
that allow more individuals
on campus at a given time.
To stay within the prescribed
density and occupancy
parameters, groups will have to
develop shift work schedules,
either multiple shifts per day
or alternative day schedules.
The committee left the
development of these plans
to each individual
faculty member
or principal investigator with
oversight from their DLC heads.
We've also discussed
additional safety measures that
have been already
described in this meeting,
and these will
include mandated use
of personal protective
equipment, daily health checks,
as well as frequent sanitization
of personal workspaces
in common areas.
Lastly, the committee
was clear about the need
during the ramp up phase to
integrate the level of research
activity across campus so as
to ensure that shared research
facilities as well as
MIT central services
are not overburdened.
And that the staff who are
performing these functions also
have safe work conditions.
So I'll stop there and
turn it back to you, Maria.
OK, and obviously, in
all of this planning,
we've been assisted by
our Medical professionals
and also we've
gotten a lot of help
from Krystyn's office in
space and many others.
So Rafael, we'll
turn it back to you.
Thank you, Maria and
thank you, Tyler.
Look, I mean, needless to
say, the research enterprise
is so important to all of us.
I'm grateful that the
people in the piece
are the two of you are willing
to just give us so much
of your time to make sure that
we bring that engine back.
Much appreciated.
Let's move quickly to
community and related issues.
I think we're ready
to go to the Q&A,
but I would like us to stop
on our cultural community.
And for that, we
have Ramona Allen,
our VP for human
resources, and we
have Jill Dozier, our
community and equity officer.
Let's start with Ramona.
Ramona, we have about 10,000
people at MIT working.
So whatever we do thinking
about the faculty and students,
clearly, we have to think
about the staff, too.
They are a significant
fraction of MIT on campus.
So what do you know about
how is the staff doing?
Do they enjoy working from home?
How are they holding out?
I think staff are coping
pretty well, actually.
I think they've done
extraordinary things
over the past several weeks.
I guess it's eight weeks now.
It's hard to believe that
that much time had gone by.
I think they're
doing extremely well.
But there are also
some concerns.
Staff want to come back to
campus just like everybody
else.
They're interested in helping
get our community back up
and running.
And they want to support all
of the efforts of the faculty
and the students, as well.
And we miss each other.
We want to be around each other.
We're social beings.
We need to be together.
I think when you look
at all these scenarios,
we have to think about how this
is going to apply to staff.
And I think first and foremost,
when people return to campus--
and it'll probably
be in a phased way--
staff need to
understand those of us,
especially in
administrative roles,
that we might not
be the first people
to be asked to come
back to campus.
I'm in that category.
When I look at administrative
people across the campus,
that's many of us who might
not be in the first round
of the reentry process.
And so I think people have
to be patient with that
and be understanding,
because when
you bring staff
back to the campus,
that means more deliveries.
Other staff will be
needed to be on campus.
We're going to need more
facility staff, more police,
more security, you name it.
So that just increases
things overall
for every single category.
And we also have to look at
how people get to campus.
So if people are taking public
transportation, for example,
you're going to have more
people on these trains.
Now it's my understanding that
there's some social distancing
measures that are being
implemented on subway systems
so that people will feel safe
when they're coming to work,
because sometimes, that's
the only way many of us
can get to work.
So those are a few things.
So there are people who will
need to have back on campus
pretty quickly,
and then there are
those who may have to wait
before we are allowed back
on campus.
And it's basically
for our own safety.
And we have to just
be patient about that.
There are masks.
Cambridge is requiring
everybody to wear masks.
Do we provide those masks?
Do we ask visitors to wear them?
How do we enforce it?
Lots of things that
are in play here.
Lots of people around campus who
are thinking about this deeply
who care about It And we've been
spending a lot of time on it.
So I think in general, staff
are handling things very well.
I think they are
eager to get back
to campus just like
everybody else.
So thank you.
Ramona, thank you.
Thank you for what
you do with HR.
I really appreciate it.
John, you have been at
MIT for how long already?
All of 49 days.
Wow, you almost have
a degree of MIT.
John, I hear that
you're organizing
a service for all staff,
students, and faculty.
So can you tell us a
little more about it?
Sure thing.
Thank you, Rafael.
One of the characteristics that
makes MIT special in many ways,
both formal and informal,
that we can connect and engage
with others in our community.
The sense of connection,
belonging, and inclusion
is vital not only to the
strength of the community,
but also to the health and
well-being of people in it.
We therefore must
ensure that we continue
benefiting to the
greatest extent
possible from the diversity
of people, perspectives,
experiences, and
engagement opportunities
that enrich our individual
and collective teaching,
learning, research,
scholarship, work,
and decision-making--
while doing
so on what is for most of us, a
completely online environment.
I'm working with Tim Jamison
and Maryanne Kirkbride
to lead a community
continuity group that's
comprised of a
representative team, who
will guide both
short term efforts
and a longer term
strategy that's
focused on these concerns.
We initially responded
to a rising community
need for essential
information and assembled
most of our online
community support resources
in one place--
on the ICO website with a
link to this information
on the COVID-19 website.
Rafael, regarding
how we will gain
and understanding
how our community is
doing specifically,
we understand
that there are many
leads that exist
amongst the members of our
community since the beginning
of our response to
the COVID crisis.
But today, we have little
empirical evidence of the scope
and scale of these needs.
As such, we're tapping
into our faculty expertise
and working with
institutional research
to administer a series
of poll surveys--
short surveys that take a
few minutes to complete that
will help us to
better understand
where to target our attention
and resources, thereby
maximizing the sense of
community, connectedness,
and belonging for all students,
postdocs, staff, and faculty.
This is one of the
many tools that we'll
be using to stay connected,
understand, and respond
to our community's balding
needs in an ongoing fashion
during the uncertain
times ahead of us.
Our plan is to launch
the first survey
before the end of this month.
And we will, of course,
share the results
with the MIT community.
If anyone has questions
or recommendations
for the community
continuity group,
I ask that you email us at
communitycontinuity@mit.edu.
Thanks, Rafael.
John, thank you so much.
Thank you for joining us.
And I bet you those 49 days
and not being boring at all.
They haven't.
Thank you, John.
So let's not move to the Q&A
part of the conversation.
Let me just say that for this
part of the conversation,
we have also joining
us to answer questions,
our provost, Marty Schmidt,
our chancellor, Cindy
Barnhart, our CP for Open
Learning, Sanjay Sarma,
and our VP and general
counsel, Mark DiVincenzo.
So Alfred, do you have any
questions rising to the top
that you want us to answer?
Yes, indeed.
We have a whole bunch of
questions-- nearly 200
at this point, and
they've all been terrific.
So just a quick reminder from
me as we move into the Q&A--
reminder, you can still submit
questions using the link
near the bottom of your screen.
We're not going
to try and answer
in the order in
which these came in.
Instead, we're focusing on
the most frequent questions.
And just a reminder,
of course, there
are some questions we
simply don't have answers
for just yet, but
we'll let you know
what we know at this stage.
And so Rafael, by my
reckoning here, certainly,
the number one
questions have to do
with budget and financial
support for students.
I think the most frequently
asked questions so far has
to do with tuition in the fall.
If it's going to be a fall
semester primarily online,
will that affect tuition,
that's one question.
And a related one has
to do with our support
for graduate students.
We know that there has
been a petition circulating
to ensure that grad students
get the support they need,
and that's a question that's
been coming up, as well.
Let's see with Marty,
our management provost.
Marty, can you answer
those questions. one
is tuition in the fall.
I think the way I
understood you now--
if it goes online, what
will that do to tuition,
and support for grad
students and the petition.
Marty, are you on?
Yeah, I am, Rafael.
Can you hear me?
Perfect.
Yes, we can.
Become accustomed to
turning off the mute.
So yeah, let me try and
answer that, Rafael.
As you know, under
our normal process,
each year, we announce
tuition and financial aid
in their early
spring, and that's
exactly what we did
this year, where
we announced tuition
and fees for next year
would increase by 3.8%.
But we also
announced an increase
in the undergraduate
financial aid budget to 7.8%.
And just as a footnote, our
undergraduate financial aid
budget for the
coming fiscal year,
we budgeted at $148 million.
But clearly, these are
no longer normal times.
And we're focused on trying
to determine what the fall
and spring will look like.
Without that picture,
it's really hard
to think about tuition in the
normal way which we do it.
So our focus right now is what
will fall and spring look like.
And then we'll
make determinations
about the financial needs for
the students and the tuition.
I will say that in
our re budgeting
process, as we experienced
in the 2009 crisis,
we fully anticipate that the
students' need for support
will go up as you
know don't have
to look any further than
the 30 million people that
have filed for unemployment.
And so for that purpose, we
have actually increased even
beyond the $147 million,
our budgeted financial aid
budget for next year.
The last thing I think
it's important for me
to point out when we're
thinking about tuition--
it's important to recognize
that 60% of our undergraduates
today receive MIT scholarships.
And actually, 31% of
the undergraduates
don't pay tuition based
upon important need.
So that's the
question on tuition.
I think you also
asked about what we're
doing for graduate students.
And this is an area that
we've been working really
hard on with both
the deans, the vice
chancellor, and the
chancellor, Cindy Barnhart.
I'll say a few
things and then Cindy
may want to say more maybe
just to correct things
that I don't get it right.
We're taking this
issue in several steps.
The first step is really
to address the concerns
about summer support.
So last week, we announced
the establishment
of a short term
emergency fund that's
going to address instances where
students' summer plans have
been disrupted and
they need support.
There's a lot of diversity in
the amount and type of need
that's needed.
And this is really based
on the vast variety
of graduate programs
that we have.
And for that reason, we're
working with each school
and college dean
to ensure that we
have the resources to
address the full need
for their particular programs.
And that those resources are
allocated in a way that's
appropriate for the local need.
I'm confident that we can meet
the full need of those schools,
but we have to address it
at that local level in terms
of assessing the need.
I've met as recently
as today with the deans
to confirm our plans
and review them.
The second step is
really to address impacts
the COVID-19 is having
on students' progress
towards their degree and the
legitimate concerns about
whether or not they're going
to be supported into the fall
term, what that means about
their support, degrees,
extensions, and the like.
And that's where we'll
turn our attention next
once we have the summer
support issue nailed, which
is obviously the most pressing.
I'd also say that I'm
really pleased to say
that last week we
announced that we accepted
the recommendation developed by
the Graduate Student Council's
Graduate Stipend
Committee, where
we'll be increasing graduate
students' stipends by 2.9%.
And we've also announced
that health insurance
rates for our Medical
plans will not
increase in the coming year.
So those are the things
I wanted to share.
I don't know-- Cindy, you
want to add more or back
to you, Rafael?
Good job, Marty.
Right.
Thank you, Martin.
Alfred, do you have another one?
I sure do.
In that same vein,
a number of people
are asking about our support
for international students, who
face other kinds of hurdles
some of them financial,
but of course, questions of
travel bans and visa issues.
So a number of
questions are asking
how MIT plans to support
our international students.
Very good question.
Maria Zuber, our
VP for research,
you want to take a shot at it?
Or maybe I'll ask Cindy--
it's OK, Maria?
OK, so I'll start, and then
Cindy may want to jump in.
So we're monitoring
the situation closely.
Of course, we continue
to be in contact
with our colleagues
in Washington
to try to explain the
importance of getting
these international
scholars onto our campuses.
We're monitoring the
situation closely
and we're in touch
with these students
to try to essentially be
ready to hit Send as soon
as the visa situation
opens up to get
everything submitted on time.
Cindy, if you want to
add anything to that.
I think maybe Mark may
want to comment on this.
Mark?
Sure.
So we understand that there
are a number of circumstances
beyond the usual circumstances
of international students
and scholars being able
to freely come to MIT
and to stay at MIT.
And so we're looking at a
number of different scenarios
in which we understand
that potentially, there
might be remote research,
remote learning.
And we have a small
group right now looking
at all those situations to
see what the options are,
what our flexibility is, what
the legal constraints may be,
what negative effects
some of our practices
might have on people's
visa statuses,
if they're now in their home
country and may not return.
All with the
understanding that we
want to support the continuing
scholarship in education
over international students
as well as the new community
members that are coming to MIT.
So all I can say is
we're working hard.
We're trying to have
flexible options.
We're working with the
international students
office, the international
scholars office,
as well as our vice president
of finance office, and my office
to come up with a scenario to
understand both the compliance
issues as well as to
ensure that we're providing
as much flexible options for
our international students
and scholars.
Thank you, Mark.
Just I forgo to ask
Maria a question.
Maria, can you say something?
I want to see you on the
screen one more time.
OK, I'm back.
At the first
townhall, I asked you
what was your screen
background and I
have to ask the
question to you again.
What is the screen
background right now?
OK.
The last time I was on
Mars, and I'm still on Mars,
but I'm in a different place.
I'm actually in the western
part of the Valles Marineris,
which is a canyon that's about
as wide as the United States.
Well, I assume that
was our right answer,
because I have no idea.
But thank you, Maria.
Alfred, you got another one?
Sure do.
And this, again, is coming
from a number of folks.
So let me start here-- actually,
maybe Bruce will help us
with these questions.
It goes back to how will
we ensure safety on campus,
Rafael, when and if students
are returning in the fall.
A few questions related to that.
A lot are asking how will we
ensure the safety of students
and staff on campus.
A related question is,
will MIT supply facemasks?
And the third in this group
is, do facemasks do the trick,
and do we need social distancing
if we're all wearing masks?
Well, clearly, I
think that Bruce
is a little more
qualified than I
am to answer the question of
face masks or what we need.
I think what I can say is that
we will consider seriously
about the supply of
face masks and how
to make things easy for
everybody in the community.
That is where we're going.
But in terms of are we
going to be asking everybody
to wear masks, if a
decision is made today
with what we know today, unless
Bruce tells me that I'm wrong,
the answer is yes.
Will we know anything in
four weeks or eight weeks
or in four months to
decide differently?
Perhaps.
I'll leave that crystal
ball up to Bruce.
But I think as you heard
Bruce's comments earlier,
a face mask is a safe way to
proceed with the knowledge we
have as of today.
And we're running
along those lines.
But Bruce, do you want to add
anything to what I've said?
OK, I guess [INAUDIBLE].
Just to agree that
I think face masks
are really a critical
component here.
And I think there's every reason
to believe that coming back
to campus is going to be
associated with everybody
wearing face masks.
It's hard for me to believe
that by September that will not
still be a recommendation.
Thank you, Bruce.
And Rafael, may I--
go ahead.
Someone else will speak.
I think that there was a sort
of related question about if one
wears a face mask, does one not
need to do social distancing?
And I think that the simple
answer is everything helps.
So most likely, face masks
will be part of the process.
And one will be advised to
practice social distancing
policies for the
foreseeable future.
Thank you, Tyler.
I missed that one.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
Alfred, you have another one?
Yes, and this is another
very, very popular question,
having to do with when we think
we'll be able to make decisions
about the fall, Rafael.
Well, let me just say that this
is a pretty serious question
that we are thinking about on
a daily basis, pretty much.
With what I know today--
and again, I rely heavily with
advice from people like Bruce
and Taylor earlier,
I mean, people
who understand this
much more than I do,
I would like to wait
for as long as possible.
But we know things
might still change.
I doubt that even if
these are still changing,
we'll wait much longer
than eight weeks
to make that decision.
So I would say that late
June, early July, thereabouts,
we should know enough to try
to make the right decision
for the campus.
But as you heard
from Bruce earlier,
things are changing
very rapidly,
and we're monitoring
that very rapidly.
If at some point in time
between now and then
we understand that
things will change much,
we'll be ready to
make a decision.
But while things are
changing and we're
learning more and
more every day,
I think the right
and responsible thing
to do is to wait until
the last possible moment,
although not much later
than early July or so on
to make that decision.
That's where we
are at this point.
Rafael, I might add that I think
that the fact of the matter
is that at the Brigham
and Women's Hospital--
I learned this morning--
despite all the COVID patients
there, despite all the activity
and the chaos that's accompanied
this surge in Boston,
there have been only two
cases of transmission
to health care workers
that were documented
that could be attributed
to something happening
within the hospital.
Obviously, MIT is not the same
as being inside the Brigham,
but it really points to
the fact that judicious use
of face masks is something that
really does make a difference.
Social distancing is not as
possible in the hospitals,
so it's probably not
adhered to as much.
But to Tyler's point,
social distancing
will also have to
be something that's
implemented and maintained.
Thank you, Bruce.
Alfred, you have
any other questions?
I sure do.
And this one, Rafael, is maybe
more specifically for you
and maybe Ramona.
President Reif, you wrote last
month that you'll do everything
you can to avoid cutting jobs.
Is that still the case?
Well, let me see
how Ramona answers,
and I'll try to
correct what she say.
Ramona, you want
to give it a shot?
Absolutely.
So layoffs are a
last resort, always.
None of us wants to go
through that activity.
We understand the
economic climate.
We know that if you were to
leave MIT to loss of job,
you're going out into a
really tough situation.
We are trying to avoid
that at all costs.
So we're doing everything we can
to think this through and make
sure a number of
people weigh in.
And those decisions are
taking very seriously.
So the goal is to avoid
layoffs at all costs.
Thank you, Ramona.
I fully agree with her.
Excellent.
I'm sure our community continues
to find that reassuring.
I want to turn to a
series of questions
now about students who
are considering perhaps
taking a gap year
or new students who
may be considering deferring.
A lot of questions have
come in about what would we
say to a student
who is considering
either one of those.
What would we say?
And hear, I know that
Ian and his group
may want to answer here.
Yes.
I can see that there
are a lot of people
would want to jump and
answer that question.
So Ian, Peko, Cindy--
who wants to take that?
Who wants to be the first?
I can take it.
They're fighting already.
Go ahead, Ian.
I can share at least
the positive news
that I think we had a record
undergraduate yield this year.
And our graduate yield is very
high, too, so a lot of people
are still very excited
about coming to MIT.
I think the hard
question for everyone
in thinking about deferrals is
what will the alternatives be
at that point in time.
And that's just a very
hard thing to consider.
But as with most
things at MIT, we
would do what's in the best
interest of the students.
I think if the
students felt that it
was best for them to defer,
we would let them defer.
So those are the kinds of
things that you know we will
I think learn more about as
we understand more about what
the fall will look like--
on the undergraduate
side, especially.
But it's a hard
question, because we
have ideas of what the campus
environment will look like,
but we don't know what the
alternatives for people
pursuing internships or travel,
which is likely to be difficult
still, will be.
And as I said earlier,
we hope to create still
a vibrant environment
on campus where students
get to spend time
with other students
and learn about great things.
So a hard question to answer.
Thank you, Ian.
Does anybody else want to answer
that question in the panel?
I'll just second what Ian said,
which is that I am not sure
that the question is
much different now
than it is at any time, right?
At any time, you're
weighing which
is the option that's
better for the student,
and I think we would
do the same thing now.
Well, I think the main point
is that we really, as we
do every year, try to make it
very attractive and exciting
for a student to
be engaged at MIT.
And whether that's on
campus so maybe some time
away from campus, we
will offer our students
an experience that
they will never
forget that is very much MIT.
That is for certain.
Alfred, you got anymore?
Yes, I have one or
two more, Rafael.
And again, I'm picking
questions or my group
is picking questions that
are most frequently asked.
Here's another one that
I think is related.
It says, transitioning
to college is hard.
Doing it online
would be even harder.
How would you support
first year students
if we're still doing
remote teaching,
even if we're on campus
while we're doing it?
Ian, I think this is a
great opportunity for us
to share a little bit of what
their students are telling us
from their online
experience, if you want.
You or Sanjay can do that.
Or maybe, since I expect
he has a lot of insight
into how our students are
reaching out both at CPW,
but also planning for fall
events, David Singer, I expect,
could give us a real
boots on the ground
kind of a view about
how our students hope
to welcome other students.
David, you're [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, I'm happy to
speak about that.
I think that our students are
already creatively reaching
out and trying to maintain
a sense of community
even without the benefit
of physical presence.
And so the student governance
process still continues.
The meetings still
continue there
was a lot of efforts to reach
out to students during CPW
that that went really well, and
was just as creative, and as
quirky, and as quintessentially
MIT as it always is.
And so I expect that's
going to continue.
And so if we're in a difficult
situation in the fall, where
there's still distance, and
there still students who
are not on campus, then
the upper class students
will reach out to them and
form a sense of community,
so that when we finally
do reunite on campus,
it's going to feel like
there actually was continuity
and community building.
Thank you, David.
Thanks.
COVID-19?
I just want to see
if anyone wants
to add to that about the
support for first year students,
if there's anything
else on anyone's mind,
just before we go on.
Because I'm going to
shift gears now to housing
if there's nothing more
to be said on that.
OK, great.
So the question is, several
things-- and Suzy Nelson,
maybe this comes back to you--
having to do with when
will we announce decisions
about housing
assignments, number one.
Number two, are we looking at
the fraternities and sororities
and other independent
living arrangements,
and how do they
factor into the mix?
And the third question
is, what's the thinking
around fall sports?
This is all Suzy.
Thank you, Alfred,
for that question.
So the first one
about assignments.
We don't really want to
start making assignments
until we know what
the program will be--
the academic program will be.
So we have a lot of
different models.
We had a good conversation
with DormCon last week.
And one of the things
we talked about--
the students suggested
that perhaps we
would do-- this goes back
to supporting first year
students-- that
maybe we would do
a virtual assignment
for new students
based on their preference.
So that would be
a very nice thing,
because then upperclassmen
could connect right away
with new students,
depending upon where they
get assigned to their house.
So more to come on
assignments and when
that will all roll out.
And it will probably
align with when
a decision is made about when
we start and how we start,
and how many people
will be back.
And that relates
to the second part
of your question, which was
fraternities, sororities,
and independent living groups.
They are a very important part
of our experience on campus.
And we absolutely are
thinking about the FSILGs
and how they will be linked
in with the housing process.
We house about 1,100 students in
our FSILGs colleges ordinarily.
So they're very important
for our housing,
but they're also very important
for just the social life
on campus--
the student social life and
organizational involvement
that students have.
And then about athletics,
no real decision
has been made with athletics.
The NCAA, they're looking
to advise schools.
And our conference, we
formed a working group
to think about this and
what it means for MIT
and members of our conference.
But decisions have
not been made yet.
Thank you, Suzy.
Alfred?
I guess the next one,
Rafael, is how are we
going to support staff who
feel uncomfortable returning
to on campus work,
but who may feel
peer pressure or direct
pressure to return to campus?
What's our overall
approach to supporting
staff in a gradual
transition back to campus--
both those who are eager
to come and those who may
be a little bit more concerned?
Ramona, you want to
take a crack at it?
Sure.
So for people who are
concerned, our recommendation
is always talk to your
manager or your supervisor.
And we can hear what those
concerns are and then make
some adjustments accordingly.
The goal is not to
have anybody come back
and feel uncomfortable about it.
I think they'll there could
be some level of uncertainty
when we come back.
It's going to feel new for
us coming back to campus
after being away for so
long, and then coming back
in a phased way.
But I think if you
talk this through
with your local
administration, and if they
need to consult with human
resources, they should do that.
And I'm sure we'll come up
with a supportive plan that
will make people feel as
comfortable as possible
under the circumstances.
Thank you, Ramona.
You're welcome.
Here's lot more, Rafael.
Maybe Sanjay has something
to contribute here
or maybe you do, too.
And this is a
question about what
we're learning from
other countries who
may be further along on the
timeline of reopening college
and university campuses.
And are we in touch with
them, and what are we hearing,
and how are we integrating
that into our thinking?
Sanjay, you want to
take a stab at it?
Maybe I'd like to bounce the
question to Ian, because MIT
did reach out to a number of
universities around the world
and get some feedback.
But Ian has been
collecting that,
because he's trying to put that
into our thinking for the fall.
Ian?
Sure.
Actually, the person
who is collecting
is Richard Lester, who did a
marvelous job crowdsourcing it
through a lot of
faculty members.
So we have lots of information--
again, a boots on
the ground kind
of a look at different
universities.
And then through
Rafael's efforts,
we've begun to establish
some discussions
with some universities
at a higher level
from around the world
and see what we can
learn a little bit in advance--
to sort of see how things
are going as they begin
to repopulate their campus.
So the short answer is,
yes, we are reaching out
to individuals at
Rafael's level, of course,
at universities--
leadership-- to
understand how things
are going-- what their
practices and policies are.
And what we're
learning, I would say,
is exactly what Bruce
and Tyler and others
said, which is masks, masks,
masks, social distancing.
Phased-- very careful,
very thoughtful.
And most of them-- most of the
other universities that have
given us information-- are
in the very early stages--
baby steps.
Yeah, I think that the masks
is absolutely the key here.
I was seeking was somebody
in Guangzhou this morning.
The university there, which
is very close to Wuhan,
and had the surge go through
that city, they've opened up
and they're using
temperature monitoring also
as a way to try
and identify those
that are a sentinel
feature of a new infection.
But the reality is
they they're not
seeing a resurgence so
far in those communities
with those implementations.
So that also, I
think, makes us all
feel more competent that
that's a good way forward.
Yes.
And the only thing that
I can add at high level,
but we are really collecting
all the information,
as you heard from others.
The only other point that I
can note that hasn't been said
is that in many labs, social
distancing is also being
translated into a timeshare.
So there are shifts to work
in the lab, whether it's
days and evenings
or eight hours,
or whether it's a Monday,
Wednesday, Friday, Tuesday,
Thursday, Saturday.
I mean, there are all sorts
of different variations
on how to handle the activity.
In many labs, the
density is pretty
high in terms of interaction.
And what I've seen
done, and I have not
seen that separated--
facemask always present.
But also, much more separation
among people in laboratories.
But anyway, we're collecting
all that information.
Nothing that we have heard--
and from what I have I read--
I have not seen the whole
very nicely organized--
but the feedback that
I've gotten directly,
that I've read, is everything
consistent with what
we hear from Bruce and
Tyler and all other experts.
So it's all trying
to do the same thing.
What we are trying to get in
addition to what we are doing
is the results they are getting.
So you just heard Bruce
describing how at Brigham
and Women's, they have
a particular database
we can learn from.
So I think that
part is also, I'm
trying to understand so I
can compare, we can compare,
how effective some
institutions are applying
the same kinds of safety
procedures or protocols
than others.
Alfred, how are we doing?
We're doing well.
I just want to let
folks know that we're
coming toward the
end of the time
we advertised, but I think
we're going to run it
a few extra minutes
here just so we can
cover a couple extra questions.
And then I know we have
a story we want to share
with the community as we wrap.
But let me just get a
few quick lightning round
questions in, if I
could, and hopefully, we
can get through these quickly.
Here's a question for
Ramona about child care.
Is MIT teeth thinking about
supporting child care options
as we begin reopening in
the late summer and fall?
So we're examining
all options right now.
We're looking for ways
to make enhancements
to the childcare benefits
that we currently have.
And we can't do anything
with daycare centers
until the governor
lifts the restriction.
But we have a lot of people
thinking about that issue,
as well.
We know the importance of
this, especially for faculty
to come back and teach
online, if children aren't
at camps or daycare centers.
So we're examining all
of those possibilities
and trying to be
creative on top of it.
Super.
Thank you, Ramona.
Sanjay, one for,
you because I know
you've been thinking about how
to bring the voices of alumni
into your planning
for 2021 and beyond.
And that is a
question from alumni.
Well they have a chance to
offer insights and advice as you
do your work with [INAUDIBLE]?
Absolutely.
I think we're all trying to
figure out a new normal here.
And there's been
references to crystal ball,
and the community
as the crystal ball.
And our alums will be
advisors to this task force.
So Rick and I
welcome their advice.
In fact, we will set
up an advisory board
for the task force for months.
Fantastic.
Krystyn, a lightning
round question for you.
Will there be a facility
for self-isolation on campus
if we have faculty, staff,
students who get sick?
That's a great question.
So we have that facility now
for the folks who are on campus.
And we do think
that there will be
for a time waves of infection or
at least the potential for ways
of infection in the area.
So we are working on plans
to have isolation facilities
as part of caring for
the resident community.
Just as a reminder, we have that
for the resident community now
as well as the
Collier Care Center
for folks who aren't part
of the resident community,
but are part of
the MIT community,
and need that isolation.
So it's a resource now.
It's a resource that we will
continue in our planning.
Thank you, Krystyn.
Rafael, I'm going to come
to you in just one second,
but there's one
question I want to make
sure we addressed for Suzy.
And that is there's a
few students who tell us
that they're struggling
with mental health
in this difficult time.
And what advice can we offer
and how can they gain support?
Thank you for that question.
So I think what's most
important is don't suffer alone.
Please reach out to us, because
we are absolutely here for you.
All of our resources
are available online.
And there is a
great website which
we will post after this
session so that you
can have easy access to it.
The other thing I
would say is make
sure you're doing all those
things, those commonsense kind
of things, to take
care of yourself.
You know, eating right,
getting enough sleep,
taking a break from Zoom,
getting outdoors, if you can.
And doing something
positive for yourself.
And I guess the last
thing I would say
is what I have been
doing is thinking
a lot about what
is right before me
that I can control and do
today, and not worrying so much
about those things
that are unknowns,
and I can't really
do much about today.
So it's kind of like the
song at the very beginning
of the session-- pick yourself
up and start all over again.
I think it's been very tough
for many of us to do that,
because it's been a
very challenging time.
So please reach out.
There are many who can
support you right now.
Thank you so much, Suzy.
Just to note, we've
had over 500 questions.
And one of the
final ones, Rafael,
is for you, and very
much on the same theme.
How do you stay positive
during this crisis?
Well, I appreciate
that question.
I'm surprised by
it, but thank you.
Look, I think there is a
little suffering out there.
Let me just start with that
because that feeling very
strongly.
I know, like I'm
sure many of you
know people who have lost jobs.
Not at MIT, but elsewhere.
I know people who
have lost loved ones.
So there is a lot of
suffering out there,
and that can bring you down.
But MIT is a fantastic place.
I'm just simply thrilled
and fortunate that I
work in a place in
which it's uplifting.
Everybody sees a problem,
they want to fix.
They want to do
something about it.
When this thing
started, the community
just got up and tried to
figure out how to help.
And I want to come back
to that in a moment.
So it's a place where
I can-do attitude.
It's a place that is optimistic.
It's a place that believes
that intellectual brainpower,
education, science, technology
can make a difference.
And that just keeps
you going every day.
And that's just part
of the DNA of MIT.
I'm just very lucky to be here.
Thank you, Rafael.
And so I think that brings
us to the end of the Q&A.
And I just want
to remind everyone
that we had such a number
of terrific questions.
We will be trying to answer
many of these questions
online on the COVID-19
pages at the MIT website.
So we'll let you know when
we've entered many more
of your excellent questions.
But I think we got to
everything that was
asked multiple times, Rafael.
So thank you and the
entire panel for that.
And now, Rafael, back to you.
Thank you, Alfred.
So this is actually, another
way you answer the question
you asked me, Alfred.
I want to just spend
just a couple of minutes
with the help of
our faculty members,
showing how he might be
has responded to such
a difficult,
difficult situation.
As you heard earlier, we
have more than 60 faculty
that are involved in all
sorts of efforts in response
to COVID-19, whether
it's providing
lifesaving medical
supplies, advanced testing.
Bruce mention about developing
new therapies and treatments
and even advancing vaccines.
And some of them even
working in cooperation
with Bruce and the [INAUDIBLE].
So it's an amazing place-- how
very quickly people figure out,
I know how to do
this, I can help,
even if that's not what they
were doing for research.
But I want to just
highlight one of them.
It's an amazing
colleague of ours.
His name is Simon Johnson.
He's a professor at MIT
Sloan School of Management.
And he has been
part of an effort
to help nursing homes across
the state to face the crisis.
So Simon, what can you tell us
about what you've been doing?
Thank you, Rafael.
Well, as you just mentioned,
we went all in on COVID-19,
like many of our colleagues,
and many people who are
listening to this broadcast.
Our focus, we decided
about eight weeks ago,
was to try and help nursing
homes, assisted living,
and other senior care withstand
this incredible and dangerous
surge of COVID-19.
And we worked long and
hard to try and figure out
how to do this.
And about five weeks
ago, I had a meeting
with the head of the
Massachusetts Senior Care
Association, Tara Gregorio.
And I thought at that
point, we'd learned a lot,
and we were quite
expert, in my view,
about what we could provide
and what nursing homes needed.
And Tara said to me,
you know, Simon, there's
one thing we need and really,
only one thing right now,
and that's more testing.
And at that moment, I
said to myself, that's
the one thing we can't do.
I don't know how to
get more testing.
And fortunately, my
colleague, [INAUDIBLE],,
who is the brains
behind this and had
a lot of the original
ideas, said to me, Simon,
call up the Broad
Institute, and see if we
can get some of their tests.
And they did
provide those tests.
And we connected them
with Mass Senior Care.
And then we needed test tubes.
So where did we get test tubes?
Where did we get the test
kits to make this happen?
MIT Medical came through for us.
And again and
again, this has been
what's our experience, Rafael,
which is we work the problem,
we try to be smart
about it-- we are MIT.
And we find colleagues.
We have more than 10 faculty
at MIT who worked on this.
We find students-- more than
50 students have helped us
with some aspect to this.
We find people all
around campus who
are willing to give us
ideas or test tubes or swabs
or autoclave the swabs.
Whatever it is,
whatever it takes,
there's always somebody
in the MIT network.
And then there are
the friends of MIT.
There are people in
the alumni network.
There's the Schmidt
Futures Foundation,
which gave us a key early
grant to make this work happen.
There's the Biogen
foundation, which
came through with a big
additional grant just now,
that has in turn
unlocked, I would
say, a change in mindset and
understanding at the state
level.
And the state has now
provided $130 million
to help nursing
homes and assisted
living and other facilities
around the state.
And now the real work begins,
because the state has provided
the money, but
what's the strategy?
How are you going to do it?
How are you going to take
ideas such as the one put
forward by Bruce Walker
several times today--
masks?
How do you provide
better PPE for the people
working in nursing homes?
How do you improve
infection control?
How do you make sure there
are enough workers who
are willing and able to work?
Now I don't have
all the answers,
but the community does.
The people around
Massachusetts do.
We can connect with them.
We can provide end
to end solutions.
We can provide all the
logistics necessary to get
the right experts from
MIT and from other places,
and other hospitals, and even, I
would say, other universities--
I use that word carefully--
in the community
applied to this problem to
help all the residents, and all
the staff, in every
single nursing home
and assisted living
in Massachusetts.
And then, Rafael,
the question is--
so this question was put to
me by the Biogen Foundation
people this afternoon-- they
said, this is great, Simon.
You're making progress.
But when can we take this
model and these ideas
and show it to the
rest of the country
and help people
everywhere in the United
States think about how
to protect the older
members of their
communities, and everyone
who works with them, and
tries to keep them safe?
So it doesn't end, Rafael.
It keeps going.
It keeps working.
And thank you, Rafael, and
thank you, everyone here,
for your leadership
and your inspiration
in these difficult times.
Thank you for your inspiration.
Let me tell that
thousands of people
watching in the townhall
that beware of Simon Johnson.
he's a very dangerous man.
This guy a few weeks ago,
maybe a month ago or so--
no two months ago--
I think he called on a Sunday
afternoon at 2 o'clock,
and he tells me, you got
to give me the governor
tonight at 7:00 PM.
I said, Simon, you're crazy.
What for?
And he explained that to me.
And I said, Simon, if every one
of 1,000 faculty members say,
I want to see the governor,
you think I should call them?
No, but this is you
have to do that.
Well, I did, and he showed
up, and he heard the idea,
and then good things happened.
So be careful with this guy.
He doesn't stop.
I want to tell you all that I
got a letter based on the work
that Simon did-- a letter a
few days ago from the head
of the state association
for seniors care.
And in that letter, he referred
to Simon and his MIT team who
supported them through
these very dark days
as our guardian angels.
So it gives me goosebumps.
Simon, well, thank
you so much for all
you're doing for the many
people have just forgotten.
Thank you so much.
Well, we're done for the day
in terms of this townhall.
I want to thank all the
panelists for participating
and for the openness.
I want to thank all of
you for participating
from all over the world.
As you heard from us, we are
facing difficult decisions.
They are very complex.
And we're going to
find ways to invite
all of you who
want to contribute
to it offer your ideas.
I also want to repeat again,
as I started in the beginning,
that we want to make
this each of us better
and with respect for everyone's
opinions and experiences
and with empathy and compassion.
Let me conclude with
something that I
said at the end of
the last townhall.
We may be in 10,000 places,
but we are still one MIT.
And as they say in the
hometown where I come from,
hasta la vista.
Thank you.
Thank you all, for, joining us.
And thank you, Rafael.
Just to remind you-- a recording
will be available at this URL
shortly for those of you who
can't wait to watch again.
And please, music
maestro, close us out.
We Can Work It Out by the
Beatles, John and Paul.
Thank you, Martin.